dane dunning goes to the mound on his
second start of his career the first
start for four innings he was brilliant
tired a bit in the fifth with seven
strikeouts one walk he has a pretty good
outing he's looking to build on that
here this afternoon
dane dunning looks like his future is
bright that's strike three a slider
boxed in merrifield one gone this one
just
baffles a very good hitter
looks to be a slider it's right
in the middle of the plate and maryfield
just couldn't pull the trigger they
should all be strikes but sometimes they
have to call the ball
that one strike three he couldn't hold
up
let's see
check swing he did go and dane dunning
in his second career start
strikes out the side
he struck him out he absolutely did
mccann snaps it to third just for fun
and there's a lot of fun in four
strikeouts two innings for dane dunning
[Applause]
adam loads it up and a base hit to
center
mccann's thinking about three and he's
got three first and third
for the sox here in the second inning in
the first hit today for the sox is
angles
nick madrigal
who had a two for four day yesterday
including a tomahawk job with two
strikes
in the third
and this to right field gives the sox
the lead
madrigal drives in mccann angle to third
and nick attacks the first pitch to
great success
lead off walks do you a lot of damage
this inning no exception he walks mccann
madrigal cashes it in going to right
field
that's his third run driven in
and what a compliment to this lineup is
a guy that you know is always going to
make contact not over swing
second base madrigal one two three for
dane dunning
boyles don't have a hit through three
just saying
boovinch is ready to go and grandahl
wants him to take a little time
he's got rhythm today and he wants to
stay in it
into center field in front of meritfield
who has to jog forward to play it on a
bunch of hops
this is probably going to start
to equate to earned runs for bubitch
because he's been falling behind a lot
in a left field base hit
he tried the off speed away and jose
went out to get it
i showed it to him once on 2-0 and
figured jose said okay i will get off
the fastball for one pitch
and i'll go up and look for something
this is a good change i mean it's out of
way but
he saw it on the 2-0 pitch he got it off
the end of the bat turned into gold with
a base hit and now another chance to
break through against bubbitch
left side fair ball down the line
tracing it into the corner
grondal scores abreu stops and james has
himself an rbi double and a two nothing
lead
james reaches out and takes this one it
looked to be a change up he takes it
right down the line
this one eats up franco at third rattles
around for a while sox have a two-run
lead looking for more
against a left-hander battling his
control but that's one of his strengths
always has been as far as pitch framing
he will buy more strikes than most
everybody in this game
nothing to buy there strike three four
innings deep
the kansas city royals don't have a hit
you just stay in that spot he put a
strikeout or a pop-up
and a pen with cordero and frye
second base madrigal
we're through five the royals don't have
a hit
it's just tuesday two nothing socks
dane dunning has gone 5-0 hit and his
day is done
as jimmy cordero tries to keep it going
out of the bullpen
and if you heard an audible sigh
of relief
it comes from everybody in the kansas
city dugout that they don't have to face
dane dunning again who was spectacular
through five seven strikeouts one walk
no hits
but his second start back from tommy
john surgery you cannot risk his future
this is a wise choice for ricky renteria
and don cooper and i think it was an
easy choice
that is another base hit and another
extra base hit
for cam gallagher and jimenez just kind
of let that one roll by him and that's
the royals first hit it comes with one
out in the sixth inning
[Applause]
merrifield goes down and gets it and he
drops it into left center field
gallagher is around third as the throw
goes to second base
so the royals are hitless for five
innings and then three batters into the
sixth
they're on the board
man how does whit do it let's take a
look at at the blue kc here for good
highlight i mean he just pulled out his
sand wedge and said all right i'm going
to just chip it over the shortstop's
head and continue to hit
close to 400 with runners in scoring
position snapped another streak for him
and witt pounds it to deep left field so
he gets the job done
wit merrifield
has his second hit of the game he has
driven in both runs for the royals today
and we are tied at two in the eighth
inning shocked the house
he was so quick with his hands on that
fastball in
seashek this guy's really tough he's
gonna get throw a bunch of sliders how
he knew that fastball was coming first
pitch barrels it
so now a huge battery here luis robert
robert in the air left field gordon back
at the track it is over
the sucks are in first place
luis roberts sends him there
5-2 your final score
ninth home run of the year he's driven
in 22 and i know there's a lot of people
that have kind of written him off as a
rookie of the year there's plenty left
in that bet folks and this was a big one
louise robert
with one swing he was hard luck out man
today
and this one leaves the ballpark and the
sox will go to minnesota in a first
place tie with cleveland